john hein feels he could beat gary
in music trivia well stop the bowie
stump the voice stop the buoy
right now gary's backing out he's afraid
of john i'm not backing out
john said he wanted to play me i'd be
happy to play him oh you guys
put up these stakes that i'm not
interested in because it wasn't my idea
to play john in the first place so they
want to
this is what they want to do robin john
and i play each other
loser never gets to vote for the rock
and roll hall of fame ever again
i didn't sign up for this isn't my idea
i don't give a [ __ ] come on you can't
beat john hein you're that guy
seriously i might be able to i mean i
used to be better well wait a minute
have you
and john talk trivia before that's all
we talk
and so he's really good is what you're
saying oh yeah yeah yeah
wow i mean gary is very good at it john
you really think you can beat him
uh look i know gary's birthday is coming
up and i thought it would be
fun if we did a stump the buoy
and he's you know the best no doubt
about it but i can hold my own and i'd
love to
sort of take him on and and see and i
feel confident in my skills
john's eyes lit up i didn't know he was
such a gambler but he lit up at the idea
of like putting up stakes
right i think it's a great cup i think
it's great if gary wins he gets to
continue voting for the rock roll
gary there have to be consequences of
losing right
robin this is something that i was not
interested in doing so how do i know
there has to be consequences
john you're okay with it right you're
willing to put it up i look i would bet
the rock hall voting but if gary's
uncomfortable with it
you know we could do it for a shorter
period of time maybe i got it i would do
a year
i would do a year okay yeah and here's
the other thing
the winner gets the other guy's votes so
you can fill you can tell him what to
send in
how's that right i'll tell you what my
money's on gary
i'm i'm mine too yeah i've seen him in
action
i'm going with experience you're going
to win
don't worry i'm going to put money that
day we're going to take bets i'm going
to put money on you yeah
okay who's betting against gary though
jd says he's betting on john
and i know why because john's is a
little oh his his
boyfriend yeah that's exactly why
yeah i'll support just for the action
you know i like
i have a little gambling uh thing with
me too so uh what do you mean just for
the action
what kind of support is that either you
think i can win i think you can
i think you can win enough to i think
enough that i'll i'll do
i'll put money yeah we'll call it bowie
versus the
fast foodie because john loves it bowie
versus foodie
bowie versus foodie